you know I mean I think we're all
looking at the at the Under Ice oceans
around the larger planets here I I would
bet any amount of money that we're going
to find something under there I mean all
the necessary requirements for the kind
of life that we think of are going to be
there
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
life on Earth should have disseminated
throughout the uh throughout our solar
system and over the billions of years
you were absolutely right the origin of
life you know better than me we believe
started about four billion years ago in
other words it's just a few hundred
million years after this meteorite uh
was created in the same proto-solar
system right the fact is we don't
observe any evidence for life in our
solar system to what extent can we use
in a Bayesian framework the lack of
observation of any trace of any
existence of life on a meteorite on uh
on another planet as some constraint on
the facundity argument that life should
be ubiquitous we haven't done the real
test first of all I mean so we sent uh I
mean actually the department that I got
my PhD in here at Stanford the genetics
department
um they actually built the experiments
that were done on Mars in the Viking
Landers uh and you know there was
there's actually been a lot of post-hoc
analysis of that original data that said
you know what this actually probably was
evidence of life but
um strangely and I don't understand this
I'm not saying that it's a conspiracy or
anything they they keep sending back
microscopes that look at rocks but they
don't send back a growth Media or
anything to try to see if something if
they were to drop a piece some dirt from
Martian soil in it if if any Critters
grow bacteria or what have you so you
know so first of all the experiment has
been done so you can't populate the
priors in the Bayesian inference uh
there
um second well Venus at least from the
you know Viewpoint of um the kind of
life that we would be looking for is is
not a not a nice place to be if you're
if you're life but you know I mean I
think we're all looking at the at the
Under Ice oceans around the larger
planets here and I would I would bet any
amount of money that we're gonna find
something under there I mean all the
necessary requirements for the kind of
life that we think of are going to be
there
um water heat uh and probably things
like hydrogen sulfide or other redox
related chemicals that would be
sufficient for growing let's say the
even primitive life will will be there
well I guess you know the my point in
bringing this up is that you know you
either have two different uh conjectures
one is that the day after we discover
unequivocal evidence for the existence
of life outside of the earth that will
transform everything and I I sometimes
feel like that stands in direct
contradistinction to the fact pattern
that we've already seen in 1996 late
1996 early 1997. President Bill Clinton
stood on the White House lawn and
announced the discovery of meteorites
not unlike this uh in Antarctica where
I've been twice and I've spent about a
month of my life there and uh it's a
Barren place it's a frozen dead
continent uh just like the ice Planet
Hoth
um I I love the people there but I
wouldn't want to live there right uh now
that was never falsified in fact there
were in order to get a NASA press
conference on the White House lawn it
had to be peer-reviewed right Avi uh and
and that your review process took place
and it's never been anti-peer reviewed
it's never been retracted formally in
the general public has already been
through this they don't know what's been
retracted if the general public you know
really hasn't gotten up in arms about
this discovery which in their minds is
still valid it's still a actual
scientific discovery what makes us think
that if you come up with proof or Avi
comes up with some discovery that
anything will be different 20 years from
now
well you know I I said this before I
think if it doesn't affect kitchen table
issues
um or doesn't challenge somebody's
religion uh or their status in the in
the world they probably will just ignore
it
um until it I I think eeks out in and
leaks out into into the general
scientific framework so that it becomes
as of many things uh it now is an
accepted fact and two years ago it it
wasn't I'm perfectly fine with the
public not agreeing with the conclusions
or any conclusions in any point in time
I'm only interested in convincing a
sufficient Cadre of scientists uh that
something is worth studying uh so that
you know continued research can be done
on it you can be spending so much of
your time uh on a no and you've wasted
you know as many months or years of your
life as possible sometimes it's easy
enough to just switch the a mode of the
question around so that it's a Zen
outcome this whole subject matter it
doesn't matter what the answer is I mean
if it's if it's no it's maybe
disappointing
but that's still interesting because
that means life on on Earth is unique
but if it's yes uh if it's yes that
there is life even on our own solar
system doesn't prove There Are UFOs or
Europeans but it is at least a step in
the direction of saying well it could
have been I'm convinced that no matter
what we find on mars or under the oceans
of Titan or what have you are is going
to be you know is going to be related to
us whether it started there and came
here or vice versa I don't really
necessarily care